[Music]
Oh,
Where?
[Music]
Shia meat.
Heat up
here.
[Music]
[Applause]
Show me.
[Music]
Oh,
Shia me.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home, but a space
to infinite possibilities,
[Music]
proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish. Completing the human
car home smart ecosystem.
Xiaomi HyperOS.
[Music]
Xiaomi.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Show me.
What?
Let's
[Music]
go.
What else?
[Music]
Shia me.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Show me.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
Xiaomi.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home, but a space
to infinite possibilities,
proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish.
Completing the human car home smart
ecosystem.
Xiaomi HyperOS.
[Music]
Xiaomi.
Heat.
[Music]
Show me.
What?
Let's
[Music]
go.
Oh,
[Music]
what else?
What?
Shia me.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Shia me.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Shia me.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home, but a space
to infinite possibilities.
Proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish. Completing the human
car home smart ecosystem.
Xiaomi Hyper OS.
Xiaomi.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Show me.
What?
[Music]
Where are
Show me.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Shia me.
[Music]
Heat.
Shia me.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home but a space to
infinite possibilities.
[Music]
Proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish. Completing the human
car home smart ecosystem.
Xiaomi Hyper OS.
Xiaomi.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Show me.
What?
[Music]
Awesome.
Oh,
[Music]
what else?
Shia me.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat up
here.
[Music]
[Applause]
Shia me.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Shia me.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt.
[Music]
Good evening everyone.
Welcome.
This is my fifth annual speech.
I've seen a lot of friends on site here
and there are many other friends joining
us online.
Once again, a warm welcome to all of
you.
On the 28th March, Xiaomi SU7 was
officially launched.
It became a hit that was beyond our
expectation. Overnight, it became a
phenomenal bestseller.
The past three months
every day, it was like a dream.
Thinking about the past 1,000 days and
nights, Xiaomi EV experienced
so many ups and downs.
Perhaps many of you know
that Xiaomi EV actually started by
accident.
It was on the 15th January 2021
at 700 a.m. on my way to work.
I got a phone call from my friend. He
said that Mr. Lei, you are under
sanction by the US government.
At that moment, it was a huge shock.
Very quickly, we held an emergency board
meeting and disc and discussed our
response.
And in that board meeting,
a board member asked, "If you cannot
make smartphones,
what about the 30 and 40,000 employees
of Xiaomi?" Indeed, if we can no longer
make smartphones, what about the 30 and
40,000 employees of Xiaomi? and one
board member suggested that perhaps you
should consider making cars.
That day in the afternoon,
it was the first time for us to have a
serious discussion about car making.
Basically, all the executives are in
support of this. But I thought car
making the risk is too big and we need
to do a very serious and careful
investigation.
Therefore we formed a team of six people
in 70 days.
We went to 10 cities
and sometimes we went to the city in the
morning and then came back in the
evening and we had 85 interviews with
over 200 people and in this process we
also had four executive meetings. In
this process,
two friends of mine have been suggesting
me strongly that we should make cars.
They are Lein and
honestly speaking
when I write my script I thought they
suggest that I should make cars. What is
it good in in this for them? Aren't they
afraid of another competitors in their
own industry?
I've been thinking perhaps they're just
thinking for me for the good of Xiaomi.
So as the investigation goes on more and
more I felt that smart EV is an
unstoppable trend. Therefore
on the 24th March when we report to the
board I said
Smart EV is a mega trend
and the car industry is being integrated
with the consumer electronics industry.
Therefore, I think Xiaomi must be
involved in this. At the same time, I
also raised my concern.
Well, the automobile industry just like
the smartphone industry where winner
takes all. Maybe in the end only five to
eight companies can survive in the
world. If we cannot become top five in
the world, we won't be able to survive
in the car industry.
Therefore, if we want to build cars, we
have to be prepared for a protracted war
and we have to become the top five in
the world. That means we need to invest
a huge amount of money in it and we
believe we need at least 10 billion US.
After heated discussion by our board
members,
they gave me a positive answer. They are
in support of Xiaomi EV.
However, because the investment was too
huge, so Lein must be the lead of this
project.
Honestly speaking, I never expect that
the board will have such a requirement.
The next few days were very struggling
for me.
It was also an eventful time for Xiaomi.
At that time we were listed two years
ago and the entire company was
transforming from a guerilla force to a
regular army. So it was very struggling
and the high-end strategy for our
smartphone business just kicked off. So
many things are happening at the same
time and at that point of time
a young executive we have cultivated for
years and we have given high hope to
also quit. It was a shock for me and
that young executive is Joe
but still
I gave him my best wishes even though I
don't want him to leave.
So in such an eventful time with all
things happening at the same time it was
a mess in my mind
and at that time I need to think whether
we should build cars or not and should I
take the lead in this project. It was
not easy.
Every night when I finally made up my
mind to do something big, then the
second day in the morning when the sun
rises, I become confused once again.
I keep asking myself,
if entrepreneurship is so difficult and
so painful, do I really want to do it
once again?
and the risk is big. What if I fail?
Will my life just end up with a failure?
And
do I really have enough
energy to really fight my way into a
brand new industry for me?
All these questions are haunting me and
I and I thought about them for a week.
It was a struggling week for me.
And on the 30th March, I officially
replied the board
that if Xiaomi must do it. If everybody
thinks that I am the right person, then
for Xiaomi, I would love to do it.
[Music]
[Applause]
It is not an action on impulse nor a
stop gap. It is the result of my 70day
contemplation. At that time
there is only one sentence in my mind.
Although tens of thousands may stand in
my way, I will continue to forge ahead.
Even though tens of thousands of people
might question me or stand in my way, I
will still be determined and forge
ahead.
That day, we officially announced that
Xiaomi will build cars and later will
take the lead. In 10 years time, we're
going to invest 10 billion US.
So, Xiaomi EV and 10 billion US
investment. This news is an earthquake
to the industry. That night we held a
press conference. Actually that day I
was not in good shape.
I was sick. Seriously, I couldn't even
talk. But on the stage
I never give myself any retreat.
I said firmly that this will be my one
last entrepreneurship and I would love
to bet all my reputations and
achievements and fight for Xiaomi EV
[Applause]
at that time on site I still remember
the thunderous applause and people gave
me a lot of support and encouragement
and online
people are saying defeat our
competitors.
At that moment I felt a whirlpool of
emotions.
That night
was a sleepless night for Xiaomi. It was
also a sleepless night for the car
industry.
I got a lot of messages.
One that touched me most was a message I
got at 5 a.m. I got a message from a
colleague.
He's
he was one of the early entrepreneurs of
Xiaomi, our number 37 employee. And
since his childhood, he has been
obsessed with cars. He thought he will
never have the luck to build a car. And
in his spare time, he built an RV for
himself just for fun.
That day, he was on a business trip in
Guangro
and he watched the launch event. He was
so excited.
Immediately he took a couple of
colleagues to drink by the Djang River.
And after that, they al they walked by
the Dujang River the whole night. Then
at 500 a.m. he finally made up his mind.
He would never miss this opportunity.
Therefore, he sent me a message
saying that as long as he can be part of
this uh project, he would love to do
anything.
That night was also a sleepless night
for many others. For example, Lee,
he was at the BMW German headquarter
responsible for the design of EX
and he was a renowned Chinese designer
in Europe
and Xiaomi's launch event shocked him
greatly. So he started to think about
joining Xiaomi.
Think about it everyone.
for everybody
to give up his job at BMW headquarter
and leave the comfortable life in Europe
and persuade your family to come back to
China. This is never an easy decision.
But
still he quit his job, get packed and
take his whole family back to China and
dedicate himself to Xiaomi EV business.
Moreover,
He visited Xiaomi twice and after the
launch events. One night he called me.
He said
that he has been in the car industry for
20 years. He worked in the public
company. He worked in the private
company. He also started his own
business. his contract with the employer
is about to do and he would love to come
out and see how an internet company
builds cars. Then he joined Shunway
Capital.
Later on he became my adviser.
So
a group of people who have profound love
of two cars come together from around
the world.
In just half a year, we formed a team of
over 1,000 people in the past 3 years.
Our Xiaomi EV department has over 7,000
people and more importantly
we have gathered over 1,000 technology
experts.
Therefore,
that launch event played a very
important role for us to build the team.
The other day I asked our HR team to
count in three years we have received
over 380,000
applications and still I want to say
that we always welcome excellent
engineer to join Xiaomi EV's team and we
want to become a global top five car
company and to this end we need more
excellent people and talents
EV has caused great social influence
some of my entrepreneurs friends are
really concerned and on April the 5th
they came to Xiaomi together with a lot
of questions in their minds and those
questions were mostly concentrated on
two issues. Number one,
is it already too late for you to go
into the business of car making?
Indeed.
manufacturing cars three years ago were
like six to seven years late.
But I answered
intelligence is the soul of cars and
in the EV era intelligence is just the
beginning.
Besides
for cars, it's a channel of 100 years.
As long as you truly love it and you
truly want to do a good job, I think
anytime is the best time
and they carried with them more
questions. The second question was then
why don't Xiaomi
go to the market independently?
Many people whenever heard hearing the
word of uh going public were
enthusiastic and also it was a popular
choice for AEV companies. Their shares
were rocketing very high and I said
indeed some VCs have given us offers.
It was highly sought after with a
valuation of about 10 billion US. Just
imagine we've done nothing yet, but we
were valued at 10 billion US dollars and
to be financed by others to make cars.
It's like zero risk for Xiaomi. Who
could reject it? So to be honest, we had
been moved. But after some thor of
thinking, we rejected the offering. Why?
Because it's a long cycle of car making.
If we took the investment of others,
And it may took us a very long time to
come to the same page which was almost
impossible.
Besides to make cars within Xiaomi
alone, we could directly employ our
available technologies
and I thought that I know it's very
challenging task. I cannot solely rely
on my own. So I must mobilize every
staff in Xiaomi with their sole support.
I hope that everyone could go all out to
the business of car making for us to
truly win in this battle. In the end, we
decided that we would support ourselves
in this business. We financed ourselves
and we carry all the risks on our own
shoulders. As long as we could make good
cars, we were willing to sacrifice
everything.
On that day, one tranu came here
accompanied them.
I still remember that later on told me
that he truly admired our courage. Still
he was kind of worried about us.
That was the story of Xiaomi making cars
in the beginning without the accidents
like sanctions by the USA. We wouldn't
rush into the car making business and
there would never be such a 7 vehicle.
So
whatever huge crisis you were wrapped up
in, never be intimidated. And the
courage to cut off all means of retreat
is the key to make breakthroughs.
[Applause]
After we make the mind to make cars,
countless other challenges remained in
the car business. Every year there was a
launch of about 200 to 300 series of new
cars. It was a very competitive market
and as a newcomer the first market car
truly mattered. What kind of vehicle
should we make
as the first one in the beginning our
team has read a lot of um reports. We
started our study and we wrote hundreds
of pages of analysis report and
I couldn't help but throw a wet blanket
on them. I said, "Don't make it too
complex. How about we just make a car
that's favored by all the Xiaomi
engineers. If we don't even want to buy
our own vehicle, it's just in vain to
produce one to the market. So, let's
simplify the whole thing." So the next
question is what kind of car is favored
by the engineers?
Our team was quite professional. Their
first instinct was to find an
investigation company which would come
up with a report after months and during
the discussion I threw another wet
blanket on them. I said that let's just
cut it off. Even when a 100 reports
could not replace a face-to-face
communication with a real user, we must
start right away.
I
asked all people
to talk with the engineers one by one.
In two to three weeks time, we
interviewed 300 engineers in Xiaomi.
After the talks, we thought it wasn't
enough. So
our team ran to the parking spaces of
Xiaomi office buildings and saw with
their naked eyes about what vehicles are
driven by the staff. I know it's a very
simple choice but it's simple but
effective. Very quickly we learn about
the price range, the types of vehicles
and the brands bought by them. for
example, it's like half and half between
the sedans and SUVs.
From the R&D perspective, it's easy to
produce the SUVs,
but not the small vehicles, small cars.
So,
most of the manufacturers started from
SUV manufacturing. But I took a
different opinion. We decided to took a
different path. We started from making
the most difficult vehicle that is the
purely EV car and then it would be much
easier to turn to other vehicles.
We determined to develop PEV.
China boasts a very mature industrial
chain. It's pretty easy to make a car.
Three years ago,
many friends approached me saying that
you were already a late comer. Just find
an OEM to produce it. Never do this all
on your own.
For the starters, we agreed. We thought
about acquisition and uh OEM
partnership. But then after a while, we
made another decision to start from the
core technologies. We didn't want to
take a shortcut. Why? Because
we've had our hard lessons before. 14
years ago when we started up our
business, we had a model innovation, a
lightweight model. We grew very fast in
the beginning. But then because we were
not deeply rooted, we encountered many
setbacks. Even today, I think we are
still filling the loophole.
So when we decided to start up another
new business segment, we didn't want to
go to the shortcut. No acquisition, no
OEM. We just work on the core
technologies and with 10 times
investment, we would love to make a very
good car.
When we made up our mind, we took solid
steps
to invest on it. For motors we have
three generations and for die casting we
have two sets of die casting equipment.
For smart auto driving we have purely
visual system and litter system. We did
the same thing with many core
technologies. Allow me to share with you
our story of the battery pack.
People may think that a battery pack is
a simple thing but not so much. It took
us like dozens of months to make such a
battery pack with tens of millions of
investments. So for the manufacturers to
produce a car, usually they prepare like
two to three battery packs
for one car. But do you know how many we
have for SU7? We had a dozen of battery
packs.
Moreover, to get a clear idea about
battery pack, we even establish our own
battery pack factory of our own. Our
team had a tough time and our suppliers
were also introduced into this turmoil.
I called the CL
CEO Mr. Jin to explain why it was so
troublesome and he said he totally
understood. He once produced a battery
for company A and for just one cell
phone in a company which required maybe
just one plan for the battery. But
indeed they developed 200 different
battery cells. In the end only one of
them was used. So he said he totally
understood only with so much efforts can
we truly produce a good product.
Just like that we started from the core
technologies with 10 times of investment
from the beginning of our project. We
kicked off the R&D on the core
technologies
and time after time
we worked like a horse intensely for
half an hour and
before the spring festival
three years ago the first time project
review
inaugurated. We were excited but after
this meeting
we had a lot of disagreements
we argued against each other for long
and in the end we decided to start all
over
during that spring festival.
We had bedtime. We were anxious about
the timetable of this project. And on
the first day after the spring festival,
I canceled all my schedules
and I gathered the core members of um
the team of the vehicle for a meeting to
think about how to start all over.
For such a temporary meeting,
it never occurred to us that it lasted
for 21 days.
It was a marathon.
At first, we were reserved and
restrained, but starting from the second
day, we had bitter and bitter fights.
Sometimes we argued from 9:00 a.m. to
9:00 p.m. for just one small issue. And
during the debate, I decided again that
whenever our team was crystal clear
about the situation, would we dismiss
the meeting?
We had about 1,000 people in the team
waiting for the results of this meeting
under the huge pressure of timetable. We
put aside everything else to argue about
this topic. So the meeting was paramount
to us because the team members came from
different places, different backgrounds.
It was the first time for us to spend so
much time to have high density of debate
face to face. During the meeting, we had
better understanding of each other and
we came closer to one another. So the
most important consensus of that 21 days
of debate was that as a newcomer, as
long as Xiaomi could make it to the card
table, it was already a success for us.
So many people asked us why could you
make a car in 3 years time. The key is
that we observe the market rules.
It comes first to abide by the rules. We
shouldn't think about making disruptions
from the beginning.
So on top of the discussion during the
21 days
dozen of people in our team
became comrades in arms. We trust each
each other and we give our back to one
another. That's why we could withstand
numberless
tasks ahead of us.
So we never thought about a meeting that
could last for 21 days after the spring
festival.
And after that meeting,
a test came to us out of expectation.
The COVID 19 hit Shanghai. Many of our
engineers were in Shanghai. What about
R&D?
They carried all their equipment back
home to do the R&D work.
One of our colleagues His
device is home.
And this is his workstation at home.
Our super motor control software
operated for the first time in the
living room of his house.
It was a memorable experience for us. We
were separated by geographical distance
but we felt so close to one another. I
still remember that many of the product
decisions about SU7 were made in such
webinars
during that time. We even held several
online parties to celebrate our success.
Whenever we had stage by stage
achievements,
we just deliver the red wines to the
homes of all the colleagues and we had
class
wine party.
Well, it is the spirate of revolutionary
romanticism that help us to conquer
different difficulties. The project is
processing steadily as planned.
And then on August 16, 2023, the first
try produced
was slowly launched
on site. Everyone was so excited.
[Music]
[Applause]
after
Xiaomi Su7
has been delivered as scheduled which is
really a miracle.
I believe that to make this miracle it
is all because about the efforts of
7,000 people of the whole team I think
we are a great team
well is out of the performance that our
expectation I still remember after the
ceremony
all the people went back home
alone I circled the tri produce again
and again alone
And finally I opened the car door
and sit for a very long time.
I couldn't believe that
we really make the car
for that moment. I was quite emotional.
In this regard, we can say that we chose
to make the hardest pure EV and we chose
to start with the underlying technology
and we chose to have a 21-day meeting at
the busiest time
take a lot of courage and determination
because we know
that only by insisting on doing the
right thing.
Can we go further?
Our Xiaomi EV can be truly successful.
[Applause]
In the past three years
I have been thinking that
since I have been let the team how we
can make the good car
I have been thinking for a very long
time later I think the answer is quite
simple
know what you do and love what you do
can we really do a good job
if we want to make cars we need to know
about cars and love cars
And then we got chance to make good
cars. And presently I think the first
time for us to build a car is that we
need to drive by ourself.
To tell you the truth, about 10 years
ago.
Because of my busy schedule, the company
assigned me a full-time driver. And then
I didn't drive much myself.
From the day I decided to build a car, I
made up mind to drive by myself.
Getting back on the road, I was like a
green hand.
Quiet power. It took me several days to
get used to that.
At that time, I asked my driver to sit
on the front passenger seat and my
colleagues told to him, "Well, you have
the great honor to have your boss
driving for you personally.
since first Xiaomi EV department. We
have uh many inventories and they have
been working in this industry for the
whole life and they have been driving
different kinds of types and they know
many things about cars. I was stressed
out
and I have been thinking I may need to
fill this gap as soon as possible. I
need to test drive enough cars
And to fill the gap,
so first I borrowed all my friends cars,
I borrowed the cars from our colleagues.
In one or two months, I borrowed them
all. Instead, I found that everyone buys
similar models.
Later on, I decided that
I need to go to the f stores of various
friends for a test drive.
At that time, for fear of being
recognized, I wore a hat and sunglasses.
I thought I was fully armed,
but it's useless. I was recognized as
soon as I went. It's quite embarrassing.
Later, I came up with another good idea.
I went around in company's parking lot
in Xiaomi when I saw a car that I didn't
driven. I
personally
then my assistant would put a note on
the car. Many colleagues would be
surprised when they see the note and
they call me to check whether is true or
not. When I borrow the cars, I like to
check with the owner. Usually I ask
three questions. The first question,
what do you think is good and bad about
this car and why did you buy this car in
the first place?
If you buy another one, what are you
going to buy?
And I usually like
then I drove it seriously for another
one or two days.
Then it's not over online. I would check
all the information related to this
vehicle and to see the reviews of the
users then wrote it down again.
Then
I fully understand about all information
of this vehicle. After that I washed the
car, filled it up and returned it to the
owner. Before I knew it,
over the past three years, I had driven
a total of 170 cars.
[Applause]
I see many of my colleagues down there.
I borrow cars previously from Thank you
so much. A few days ago, I sorted out
notes and materials and there are there
were over 200,000 words of information.
I took it seriously to fill the gap.
Meanwhile, I also read the by opera
feeds of these car giants.
I even watch all the racing movies I
watched when I was previously. I used to
see the fun.
I really look at the cars
after watching those movies. I was quite
impressed impressive.
Then I found out that it makes sense
that the competitors are doing well
since the bosses of these competitors
are all racing drivers.
Then I thought by myself. So maybe I can
make a small go by myself.
So can I be one of the best drivers
among bosses of domestic car companies?
Just be one of them.
[Applause]
I just want to be modest.
I even wondered if I could drive a race
car as well.
At first, I think this idea was
far-fetched. is it it was a bit
dangerous to drive race cars and people
usually start racing cars in their
teens. So, do young people like me still
have the chance to drive a race car?
I thought about it for a long time and
finally decided to try. If you want to
drive a race car, we have to get a
racing license.
I got the racing license in the
summertime.
Whether you know about racing,
we know that
usually racing cars have to be modified
for weight reduction. Everything that
can be removed from the car was removed
and AC is also removed for summertime in
Beijing is about 30 or 40° and inside
the car is about 60 or 70°
which is very hot. Ladies and gentlemen,
you can see the pictures of me when I
was learning to drive.
While we weren't the racing suits made
of bioresistant materials
with such a big helmet
and the sports seat give us a good sense
of road condition, but is terribly hard.
People may don't understand why these
seeds are so hard for this kind of
vehicle because it can give us a good
sense of road condition. You can sense
even the rocks on the track
for for example
the performance cars always have very
hard seas and the six way
is extremely tight
and you feel quite uncomfortable.
Well
after
All the armed you can see is quite
handsome but is actually very
uncomfortable. After dozens of laps my
whole body was soaked and I felt like I
was
treated
all over
a green hand and we often heat
protective wall brushed out.
It's very easy for us to heat the
protective wall. And there is a term
called heating the protective wall
and we feel quite proud if we heat the
protective wall.
Usually we know that it's a big deal to
heat a car while driving. However, when
we drive the race car, it just a normal
thing
and there's no insurance for racing cars
and each goes bad and if you get heat
you should consider yourself unlucky.
So once we got heat we just go back home
and fix our cars by ourselves.
Every time we feel very quite thrilled
because previously we were so careful
when we drive
but in the track we often hit the ball.
In this regard,
it seems that quite
dangerous to race and is indeed unsafe.
Here I would like to remind you that
when we drive the race, we need to pay
attention to safety
and your cars must be modified and we
need to modify the brakes, the seats as
well as the hardness and even installed
a road cage.
If you abide by rules and followed
professional guidance, the safety factor
is still quite high.
So the trainer has told us several times
we need to abide by the rules.
So that is the rules when I attend a
test in order
to practice. I also bought a seven
simulator and practice secretly at home.
I suffered a lot but I got a license
successfully.
Well, I learned by myself. I also
encourage our Xiaomi team to
well our management team as well as the
engineers in total 100 person license
because believe that
[Music]
A team that chose
have the ability to cars. Well, do you
agree?
I'm still you
races and we also organize internal
competitions.
I will also share with you
the car in front is mine
car trying to overtake me when
out during the U shape turnuply
[Music]
for the second line in the same place
same corner
is also the U-shaped turn and knock me
out again.
I was here for two times and cost a lot
of money to fix the cars.
Well,
when I practice racing,
I have better understanding towards
racing.
Previously, I have never experienced a
floor
and more oil
and I didn't know that how to make turns
and how to have precisions
and I really know about the secrets.
Therefore, I know more about uh the
human car harmony.
Therefore,
I think after learning my uh racing
license, I really learned a lot. It was
very helpful and for
every part of the R&D process, I can get
involved. Personally, at the end of
2022,
our prototype car started the winter
test.
It was in
it was minus 34° outside very cold. This
is the very first major test to Xiaomi
SU7 and I attached great importance to
it and the management team and I were
there. The person responsible for the
winter test was very surprised to see
me. He said he was in this business for
20 years. This is the first time for a
chairman of a car company to be part of
the winter test. the very first time
and at dinner he also asked the
restaurant to add another dish because
the chairman was here.
The second year I also participated in
the summer test in Turpin.
You know, summer in Tan, the temperature
was so high, as high as 50° outside.
Think about it. Your car under the
sunshine
if you put it outside for the entire
noon. Can you imagine how hot it is?
Some some cars inside the temperature
can be 90°.
So when I get off the car, I thought
sunblock was very important for SU7
because that can help us lower the
temperature by like more than 10°
compared with other cars. Summer test
was also difficult, but we also had
wonderful memories. I can still remember
the watermelon in Turpin.
You know watermelons in Turpin, they are
big and sweet. Usually one watermelon is
about 20 kilo.
They taste good and they are super
cheap.
Usually the price is accounted by kilos.
You know how much is 1 kilo in Tarpan.
It is 5 cent per kilo.
And our team in Tarpan they told me that
now the price is even cheaper 3 cents
per kilo. So for a 20 kilo watermelon,
it only cost you like 3 R&B. It is so
cheap. And I even carried four to five
watermelons back to Beijing. And I have
to pay a lot
because you need to pay the extra in
order to get them uh transported to
Beijing. Moreover,
because this is the first time for
Xiaomi to build cars, so quality is
paramount for us. In January this year,
we also organized the largest road test
in the industry.
We used 576 prototype cars and tested in
300 cities in on all the roads and the
total testing mileage is over 5.4
million uh kilometers. I think you have
seen our testing fleet this year. So the
coverage is wide and this is the largest
road test in the industry. And some
people online say that whether Xiaomi EV
is good or not, it is all about whether
the executives of Xiaomi have the boss
to drive it because that was still the
prototype cars.
So
do you have enough courage to drive it?
An engineer saw this message and posted
this message in our group chat and at
me. I understand what he means. Then
quietly I forward this message to our
group chat for the executives and asked
everybody in it. All the executives of
Xiaomi immediately responded to this and
they all participated in the road test
and they want to use themselves to prove
the reliability of SU7. So all the
executives of Xiaomi before the launch
of SU7 tested SU7 for 100,000 kilometers
and I participated in over 10 tests and
a drove for about 5,000 kilometers and
what I can still remember the most is in
January this year from Beijing to
Shanghai
from se 6 a.m. to 900 p.m. 15 hours I
drove alone and I drove
1,267
kilometers, I never thought I could
drive alone for such a long distance.
So, thinking about this, at first, our
PR colleagues don't allow me to do this.
They're not worried about SU7. They're
worried about me. They said, "Mr. Lei,
if you had an accident on the road, it
will certainly become a PR crisis for
us." So, as I drove, their eyes are all
on me. They're even more nervous and
anxious than me. But the whole thing was
a success
and
you know to drive on the highway plus
our smart driving system. I think the
experience was wonderful for me
and I was also surprised by the test
because you know in winter and on the
highway the range of Xiaomi SU7 is very
reliable and I was very confident about
it. It is because of our investment and
a dedication to battery technology. So
Xiaomi SU7 can have such a wonderful
performance in terms of range. So so far
I've relearned how to drive. I learned
how to race. I participated in the
winter test, the summer test and also
the long distance test.
All of these seems very easy and simple.
But what I feel is that
courage is never a slogan.
It is each and every step you take. Do
you agree with me?
At this point,
people online in the past few months uh
have asked me to show them my drifting
skill and I remembered in one live
stream I said that I know how to drift
and after that people urged me to show
them my drifting skills and uh I really
can drift but I'm not very good at it.
May if I show you this video I believe
many experts will criticize my drifting
skills.
Since it has been a long time and so
many people have urged me, so I recorded
this video to show you my drifting
skills. It is not very good just to show
you and don't watch it frame by frame
just for fun. Okay? And it looks very
cool.
Let me show you this
my performance of drifting.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
[Applause]
Heat. Heat.
Settling up for that rodeo.
Are you
settling up for the ride?
[Applause]
Thank you very much. Thank you.
So because of this exciting project, I
have to thank the accident three years
ago. This is why I can join such an
interesting industry.
So this
is how we worked so hard for three years
in the process of R&D and we have been
very low key and we didn't do any
communication or publicity. So anything
you saw at that time it was only a
leakage. We didn't do any publicity and
last December it was the first debut of
uh Xiaomi EV and many people thought it
was all of a sudden it was like
groundbreaking.
Therefore, at first it was a hit. It was
so popular. But a few days later,
we saw a great number of questions,
slanders and criticisms. Very often
people said that your competitors cannot
do it in 10 years. How can Xiaomi do it
in 3 years? This is a very difficult
question for me to answer. How would I
know why my competitors cannot do it in
10 years? Why don't you ask other people
how many years does it take to really
develop their cars? I think this
industry is mature and 3 years is just a
standard time for you to develop a car.
So I don't know how to answer this
question. So we have seen so many
criticism online and our competitors are
also making jokes of us and they made
fun of us.
And there was a saying online. I think
you have all heard of it. Mr. Lelay,
stop.
[Applause]
[Music]
You have seen this, right?
I think none of these are important.
The real difficulty is that we have
dedicated everything to SU7
and um it took 7,000 people and it took
countless hour to develop SU7 because of
because we need to keep it a
confidential before the launch and two
to three months before the launch when
we talk with our friends everybody
believes that the sales won't be good.
I told them that our configuration and
our experience are way better than our
competitors. But they told me that the
buyers of a the buyers of other products
they are fans of Elon Musk they won't
buy SU7.
Then I asked maybe for uh 34C which
represent BMW 3 series Audi A4L and
Mercedes C-Class their users needs to
upgrade right they want to buy a
high-end smart vehicle right you know
34C represent BMW 3 series Audi A4L and
Mercedes C-Class they are actually the
entrylevel product of BBA
so I thought maybe the user of 34C they
need to upgrade their car to a smarter
EV at a similar price only the product
is better and several department
wrote me three reports
each report was was about dozens of
pages and after I read all of them there
is only one conclusion so those users
they only buy brand and why should why
should they buy SU7
and I don't know how to answer this
Moreover,
the sun block features and also the good
looking design we made for the female
users. They say the female users will
not buy a performance car.
Then what now? We spent three years. We
dedicated over 10 billion to develop
this car. However, the sales won't be
good and we can't sell it. Then I asked
the marketing team to invite some media
friends to help us. We invited 23 media
friends to help us and I never thought
that most of them
still don't think we can sell this car
very well
and they believe we will be very
fortunate if we can sell 3,000 SU7. This
is the conclusion they had and I think
they were very honest but I don't agree.
So I try to persuade them.
Of course they know this industry very
well and they are more experienced than
me. So I talked for two to three hours
and I couldn't even talk more. But still
this won't change their conclusion
and this made me very desperate. The
entire team was caught by anxiety. I
don't know if you still remember maybe
in March this year,
many people say that I look very pale
and there were several photos of me
looking pale online.
I was really frustrated at that moment
and
just then I was hit
by a car that I tested.
It was a car of my colleague and I
borrowed it for days to have tech test
drive. It's a Ford Mud. It's a 400,000
R&B unit of performance vehicle. And
that colleague told me that that was his
dream car.
He worked for 10 years time and he saved
some money only to buy that dream car as
a bonus to him. And according to him,
every morning when he got on board the
car to go to work and he uh slam on the
oil and he felt invigorated. And every
night coming home, he preferred to stay
in his car for a while before going
upstairs. I could still remember his
words and how shocked I was listening to
him.
I do believe
that we deserve a bonus. And that's the
significance of a dream car.
An SU7 was just designed for such dream
seekers.
I am convinced
that people's aspiration for dream car
is real and I also believe that with
three years of efforts of our whole team
would return and I'm also convinced in
the charm
of SU7.
So no matter how many people thought low
of SU7, I remain confident about the big
sales of SU7
and
the real test came to me in February
this year when I was pushed to decide on
the capacity of production. It was a
complex issue with a very long supply
chain and we have to decide how big
should be the order. Some people
recommended 30,000 which was a
conservative idea. I had dilemma
if it's set too high I'm worried about
the sales and if it's too low target
people may complain that it's just a
hunger marketing. I remember that I was
interviewed by CCTV
talking about this dilemma
of setting the order target
and in the end my confidence
enabled me to make a decision. So take a
guess what's the target in the beginning
of this year 76,000.
What did it mean? If you exclude the
uphill time, the monthly sales was
10,000 and there was only one competitor
in terms of that absolute number. So, we
ranked among the top two in the
beginning. What if we failed to sell?
You may have no idea for the EVs.
You may think that my factory is pretty
big, but that factory could only
accommodate three days of inventory.
Just imagine how big
a factory that can accommodate 1,000
vehicles. If you have 10,000 cars as
inventories,
it would be just part up all over the
factory.
And that's quite a disaster if we fail.
And I realized how crazy a target was to
be set at 76,000. But we had no step
back.
We were crossing the river. All we could
do is to charge ahead.
[Applause]
With that anxiety, we were so close to
the launch time in mid-March before the
presser.
We had the only one interview with the
media for test drives and the media
friends got in contact with SU7 for the
first time and they had a different idea
about us. Some of the media friends said
that it's unimaginable that this is the
first car produced by Xiaomi. It has
such a high rate of completion with high
value added and it looked classy and
according to them Xiaomi must have some
talented people behind it.
Listening to their comments, I was
finally relieved. But the next big
challenge is pricing.
With wrong pricing, there would be
catastrophes. there might be tens of
billions of losses and three years time
will just uh badly spent.
But for EVs, it's a completely different
car because an EV includes EEV or PHEV
or even hybrid. But for PEV, it's very
costly
except just one competitor. Maybe the
other competitors of pee had a loss
altogether. So if we set the price too
low, it's just a temporary expedient.
Some rumor went online that we may set
our price at um like 149,000 or even
99,000.
That's just misleading.
bigger pressure comes from inside.
Our salespeople
were old hands.
They were experienced and
still they lacked confidence in PEVs.
One day before the presser
in our discussion of pricing which
lasted not long but witnessed fierce
arguments
I held that SU7 configuration and
experience could rival our competitors.
I think we shall be brave to set the
price at 215,900.
which was already 30,000 cheaper than
our competitor. But still our
salespeople were worried.
After my talk,
all the people in the conference were
silent. I felt helpless among the
silence
and it was broken by one executive. He
said that
said it no matter how many we sell, we
would just take it.
[Applause]
On March the 29th, which was the time of
the launch, I was nervous and my throat
was sore when I stepped on the stage.
It felt like uh going for the GAO
examination after 10 years of hard work.
And I didn't get relaxed until I talked
for 30 minutes on the stage.
When I shared who was the target
consumer of SU7,
a lot of words that were buriating my
heart for three years time will burst
out for this group of consumers. They
didn't want to take mediocrity and
they're still fighting for their dreams.
They have flames in their heart and
lights in their eyes. They aspire for
high technology and they are shining
with confidence and optimism.
When I announced the prize,
applause sounded on the site and I felt
relieved. I think we made it for
after that launch. I took some media
interviews.
One of our colleagues dashed inside to
tell me excitedly that within 4 minutes
time we exceeded 10,000 and within 27
minutes the order went up to 50,000.
Everything looked romantic. All the
grievances, misunderstandings in 3 years
time disappeared.
And he also told me that many users
without any test drive or even a glimpse
at our car booked it.
A friend shared with me about the story
of Xiaomi fans. I was moved.
His name was Shenli, a 39year-old
professor of math school of Suchan
University.
He was our follower and he's been
supportive of Xiaomi for years. Three
years ago, when Xiaomi announced our
decision to manufacture cars, he thought
it was the critical moment of Xiaomi and
he must step up to support us. And
instantly he bought a parking space in
his neighborhood to save it for Xiaomi
vehicle.
[Music]
On the night of our launch, he placed
his order and finally the empty parking
space left there for 3 years time waited
for the moment as you said. So you could
imagine the confidence given to Xiaomi
by our fans.
So dear all,
let's take another look at
when I bowed to open the gate for the
owner of the car.
I was truly grateful to our fans.
[Applause]
That move was popular online. The
headline went
the CEO opened the gate for the consumer
and many other car manufacturers prefer
to open the gate for their consumers
later. And when it came to the auto
China, I became the marketing god and
even the traffic on the moon. People
joked that previously in the Beijing
auto show they looked at the show girls
but now they are looking at the bosses.
So I know all this
came from the great success
and charm of SU7
on that basis
and with the joint efforts of all our
partners. Amen.
We readjusted our delivery goal. By the
end of this year, the bottom is 100,000
and we would aim higher at 120,000.
[Applause]
Since we just got marketed in April,
that left us only nine months to catch
up in order to aim at 20,000
for the entire
supply chain. all the partners of Xiaomi
included. It was a huge challenge,
but it was our commitment to the Xiaomi
followers.
The first
was a victory because of SU7 and Xiaomi
finally made it to the cart table. But
we still have a long way to go before we
realize bigger victory and our long
march just got off to a start.
The past three years for me and for
Xiaomi
was a process
of reshuffling.
Xiaomi SU7's success
was the result.
courage.
It's not the courage of one person but
rather that of 40,000 colleagues.
Courage doesn't
it has no fear but rather in front of
fear we remain
and courage comes from firm confidence
burning enthusiasm and every solid step
we make.
greatest to him of mankind.
Dear friends, I hope that anytime you
could always
decision to march forward and to blaze.
So that's about our
stage. you would
have a short break and the second
session for new products launch will
show foreign
[Music]
speech.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
for
[Music]
speech.
I can't get Yeah.
[Music]
CTPG.
Foreign
[Music]
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
every
England.
Foreign
Fore
speech.
[Music]
Welcome back. Now we will start the
second session
and get please give me a warm apploud.
Thank you.
Today we have prepared many stunning
products. But first we're going to
release two portable flagships. A large
one and a small one. And first let's
release the large portable flagship. And
this is the first generation of the
large portable mobiles which is quite
stunning. Now let's look at a video
clip.
But last year the reputation of foot
three was really good. For the very
first time we achieved both thin flight
and our round flagship
in one machine. this year and we do
better.
First of all, we develop top our RAM
flagship and meanwhile make it the top
level.
Besides, we want to make it the lightest
and thinnest within the industry. Now,
let's have a look as a large model and
how light it can be.
Well, it's lighter.
It only has 226 g.
It has surpassed all the other
affordable flagships.
It becomes thinner
at just 4 59 mm when unfolded
and just a little bit thicker than the
same card slot
and when we fold it is only 9.47 mm. It
also surpasses
many flagship portable machines.
In this regard, I would like to share
with you that the handfield is
excellent. Well, it's out of your
imagination
is comparable to that of the flat
display flagships. Why is that?
First of all, it features quart curved
display
and meanwhile it is equipped with the
quad curved back and the curved mento
frame.
Equipped with so many different
technologies. It only has 0.9 mm. It
feels so amazing that when you hold it
and you even forgot that this is
affordable mobile
by saying this way you may not
understand. I strongly recommend you to
our stores to have a look and feel it
within your hand. But we also invite
many people to feel it blindly. And the
majority of people believe that for this
large verable and it handled is better
than that of the flat string once.
[Music]
Fore
62%
of the people believe that it has a
better hand feel.
For such a complex portable machine to
make it so thin and light is a complex
thing and it needs a series of
technological innovation. I'd like to
share with you several points but first
of all is about the proprietary hinge.
It is the core device. Well, we have our
proprietary hinge which has been
upgraded to the second generation this
year. Well, it uses the most advanced
three element connecting rod structure.
Last year we have already made it so
thin and this year we make breakthroughs
and narrow it and it becomes more
precise. Now let's have a look.
The first element narrowed 8% 28% for
the second element and 26% for the third
element. In total 34% narrowed.
So as you can see the total number is
34% narrow road and width has been
reduced by 117.7%
weight has reduced by 16% and the water
job arch has reduced by 15%.
So it becomes more precise compared with
the last generation.
So how precise it is as you can see
and we the amter is only 1.8 8 mm
and just like half the rise
and it has a 12
and error is less than 0.01 01 mm with
such a precision that we can generate
the best hinge
and it also adopts the 1,800 amp high
strength steel has very high stability
and the proportion of the high strength
skill accounted for 82.6%.
How strong is the strength of the hinge?
Well, this is 2.0 generation of
proprietary hinge. It is quite thin and
it's reliable and it can shoulder about
uh 500,000 times of folding. We have a
test to see the pressure.
[Music]
[Applause]
Have you seen it?
When it comes to the 59 km, it has been
crushed and our hinge is too perfect.
Well, our hinge is small and reliable.
And second is about the whole carbon
architecture.
Do you know more about it? Well, it
refers to the carbon fiber in order to
be strong
and to reduce the weight. And for the
first time, we have been using this
whole carbon architecture within our
mobiles. Well, we have been using the
T800H high strength carbon fiber. Well,
is strength has reached 5,500 amp and
impact resistance has been increased by
300%.
With such advanced materials and we made
it,
we have achieved 100% carbon fiber of
the hinge plate as well as the screen
lining and the middle frame battery
component
with so many carbon fibers. is quite
thin and has extremely high strength.
So, what about the level of the
strength? How strong it is? Let's take a
look at the test.
Well, within the 1.5 m of the extreme
testing, well, it's still perfect
without any
harm.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Isn't that amazing?
And for the first time we adopted the
whole carbon architecture which is quite
expensive but it has its own advantages
is quite light and has very strong
architecture.
Besides
well it is a system when we have the
stacked design and we need to carry out
a lot of innovation. Another example is
about the motherboard.
Well, we have very precise motherboard.
Let's have a look. This is second
generation, the third generation. And
this is the new one we are going to
release tonight.
As you can see, we have more components.
However, we have less size of the
motherboards. It only accounts 80% of
the previous one. Within such a small
motherboards, we have been using so many
different in total 205
2,500 components and uh we also have 857
of the ultra miniature components.
So how did we do it?
Let's take a look.
So layer by layer we stack the
motherboards. It is like we made a
five-story building on the motherboard.
Three motherboard and a five faceted
design.
And this is the most advanced design for
the motherboard
in such a light and slim foldable
display with extreme stacking.
We also support five 50 watt wireless
charging. And this is the first time for
us to use IPX8 on a football display.
Therefore,
when we make it lighter and slimmer, we
have done a series of technological
innovation. Let's take a look at a video
to see the technological innovation we
have made on this portable display.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Wow, it is incredible.
We can say this is the best performance
among all the foldable displays. Maybe
you are also curious
how such a slim and lightweight
smartphone can become a top
configuration all round flagship. Let's
take a look at the display because the
core of the foldable display are the two
displays on it. The outer display is a
standard flagship flat screen and the
inner display is a foldable 7.98 in
display. So the outer display is like a
flagship flat screen and the inner
display is the size of an iPad mini. So
compared with a flagship flat screen,
the cost of this foldable display is
seven to eight times. So these two
displays are the most expensive. And
these two displays are topnotch.
First the outer display. It is a quad
curved display.
We also used the Xiaomi shield glass to
protect it. Therefore, it drop
resistance is better. For the inner
display, it is a polless plus display.
It is a super low energy uh consumption
display. We also use the UTG glass to
protect it. Now some competitors are
still using the CPI but when you use the
phone for a long time there you can see
the crease on it. So both of them are
the top-notch displays in the industry
for this display.
They all they both have 418 PPI 3000 nit
peak brightness 1 to 120 Hz adaptive
refresh rate. They both have PWM and DC
demonings and they are also professional
true color displays. So they are the
top-notch displays.
At the same time,
it has the best performance. We're using
the most advanced Qualcomm processor.
This is the Snapdragon 8 Gen 3. It's um
LD LPDDR and UFS are the best. It also
supports Wi-Fi 7. It also has a massive
VC cooling. In addition, we also have
four self-developed Surge T1 signal
amplification chipsets. Its cellular
performance is improved by 58% and Wi-Fi
Bluetooth performance is improved by
16%. As a top-notch flagship, it
supports two-way satellite
communication. Moreover,
it is also suitable to use it when you
abroad. We now support 180 countries and
we also support over 500 operators.
In addition, when you arrive in a
different country, we also provide you
with 300 megabytes traffic for free.
And also the biggest challenge for
affordable display is the battery life.
When we designed this phone, our goal is
to make it have the best DOU. So, how
good is our battery life in such a slim
disfordable display?
It is powered by a 5100 milliamp hour
battery. We now use a more advanced
Xiaomi surge battery. So, it has a 5100
mAh hour battery. It is 300 mAh hour
more than the last edition.
And the last edition is thicker than
this edition. It only has uh 4,800 mAh
hour. But this one slimmer but 5100 mAh
hour. It supports 67 watt turbo charging
and the 50 watt wireless charging. In
addition to the Xiaomi surge battery,
what are the other technological
innovation? Let me mention another one
for you which is very important. We used
Xiaomi stacked cell battery in it.
First of all, let me tell you stacked
cell battery. What does it mean?
Usually the traditional battery is in
the form of a cubic but this time in
order to maximize our use of the inside
space we make it a atypical form like
this.
Secondly, in in the past, in order to
improve the production efficiency,
usually the batteries are winding, but
there are still spaces at the corners.
But this time, we make it a layered
battery technology so we can maximize
the use of the space. Therefore, you can
have an addition additional 260 millia
hour battery. Therefore, we are actually
pursuing the extreme technology. In
addition, our battery management system
has four Xiaomi self-developed surge
chipsets. On the basis of G1 and P2, we
used another R1 chipset to improve the
charging and discharging efficiency.
Therefore, we have done a series of
optimization. The DOU
it first come with the battery. Secondly
is our comprehensive technological
capability. With a series of technology,
the overall energy use of of this phone
goes down by another 13.5%.
Especially we used a low we used a
energy saving display. We can save a lot
of energy compared with our competitors.
Let's compare it with a competitor. You
see it battery is more or less the same
with fold 4. But you can see the DOU.
We are 51 minutes longer in terms of uh
DOU. We are 51 minutes longer than our
competitor.
So when this fold 4 is launched, I would
love to invite our media friends to test
it. You will be surprised. Now let's
move on to image. Many people are
curious
in such a slim foldable display. Uh will
the image capability be discounted?
For many competitors actually their
imaging uh system is not as good. So now
let's take a look. So quad camera across
all focal lengths. This is the only
foldable display that maintains the quad
camera across all focal lengths. For
many competitors because of the pressure
they have to uh change to three cameras
and for all focal lengths they are all
large apertures. In addition we also
have a five times periscopic telephoto
lens. Incredible isn't it?
Furthermore, we have a dual telephoto.
We also have a two times telephoto with
floating focus lens. You can use it to
take macro shooting. So, the shortest
focal length is only focus lens is only
9 cm and all cameras are like a optical
lens sums. With all this, this is a
topnotch flagship imaging system. Let's
take a look at some example pictures.
This is the ultra wide angle. And this
is the main camera in dim light.
And this is the portrait using the two
times telephoto camera. And this is uh
the five times periscopic lens.
It is a picture of the flyboard. It is
very cool, but I don't know how to how
to do it. And you can also use the five
times periscopic lens to shoot closeup.
I will not elaborate on all of them but
I am very confident to say that
this time the mix fold 4 is definitely
the best in terms of imaging capability
and performance.
It is boosted by hyper Xiaomi hyper OS.
This time we paid close attention to
software adaptation. For the top 500
applications we have high quality
adaptation
and our definitionation is that for high
quality adaptation it must support full
screen parallel windows you can also
rotate to horizontal screens. So this
time we have high quality adaptation and
we also support over 100 document
formats and you can also use the Apple
office apps
if you want to use the inner display it
is very easy and you can also use it for
video conference because you can fold
the display and you if you use it for
entertainment you can use it to watch
videos
and with a foldable display you can also
use the simultaneous interpretation
function When you talk with a foreigner,
the outer display will show the local
language and the inner display will show
the Chinese. We support 12 languages
now. So when you travel abroad, it will
be very easy for you.
So this is the top configuration all
around flagship affordable display that
is slimmer and lighter and we have did
several technological leap frog frog and
also the reliability is greatly
improved. It comes in black, white, and
blue.
And this is a bright and high, highly
saturated blue. Very beautiful. Last
year we launched the Xiaomi composite
fiber edition. It was warmly recognized
by the market. This year the material is
further upgraded. The strength goes up
by 42%. It is 25% stronger and the
impact resistance goes up by 15%. Making
your phone stronger and durable and the
patterns are finer and more delicate and
exquisite. Therefore, this year we also
have the Xiaomi composite fiber edition.
So, this is the Xiaomi mixfold 4. It
looks very good and also the experience
is wonderful. Let's take a look at some
pictures. It is very lightweighted and
the white is also very beautiful.
OS
the inner display uh hyper OS can gives
you a wonderful experience. You can hold
it easily in your hand for such a top
configuration all round flagship for
such a slimmer and a light affordable
display. How much is it? Let's look at
let's look at the last edition. Compared
with the last edition,
our battery is 5100 mAh hour. We have
IPX8. We also have two-way satellite
communication
also the processor and others they are
all upgraded
and compared with the last edition you
see how light and how slim it is. It is
incredible and also we invested a lot in
it. For example the full carbon
structure the Xiaomi proprietary hench
2.0 and also
the triple layer uh pentaceted
motherboard design all of them requires
a lot of investment so for such a
topnotch flagship affordable display
honestly speaking I don't know how to
describe it how much is it
[Applause]
same with the last edition
this is a very cost effective smartphone
value for money. It comes in three
editions. 16 + 5 5 20 uh 12 9,999
16 GB plus 1TB 10,999.
So this is the Xiaomi Mix Fold 4. Now
let's move on to the Xiaomi Mix Flip.
Many people ask why do you launch a flip
so late?
Five 5 years ago we started the pre R&D
and 3 years ago we approved this project
but we never launched the product
because we think the technology for flip
is not mature. Many people say that a
flip is a good for nothing.
Truthfully I used many flip phones. I
don't think they are easy to use. So
after three years of hard efforts, we
believe Xiaomi mix flip can radically
resolve the pain points in the user
experience and we want to reverse
people's impression on flip as a good
for nothing.
After using mix flip, I hope people will
say this is a good for everything.
So now let's take a look. First it's
is a good looking
for flip phone. The appearance comes
first and then let's see if it's user
friendly.
[Music]
[Applause]
Stay last. All you got to do keep it
fresh.
[Music]
Don't you say I don't need much.
Say all you got to do. Keep it fresh.
Fresh.
Just keep it fresh.
Keep it fresh.
Very beautiful, huh?
More information to share. The glossy
metal frame, lea photography all around,
liquid display.
It's a quad display and also Xiaomi
shield glass, curved back, good grip.
Also, for such a flagship flip, it's
only 192 grams.
It feels nothing on your hand, easy to
carry, portable,
and very easy to carry in your pocket
and easy to hold. We have colors of
black, white, and also purple.
It's a light purple color.
used a glitter sand glass with silk like
scents
and very exquisite with no finger print
left on it. We also introduced a nylon
fire edition. It's a new material. It
has ultra resilient fiber braiding and
unique 3D patterns.
It feels very smooth
just like the girls handbag.
And also we have two top configuration
flagship screens. One is 4 in, the other
is 6.86 in for the two displays. They're
both 1.5K with high DPI
with the same material for
brightness and they were used together
with very good user experience. Outer
screen is also adopting the shield
glass. The inner display adopts the UTG
ultra thin flexible glass. So it's very
durable.
Two top configuration displays.
Just like the fold flip can also endure
500,000.
I've used the flips before. People
complain
about the trouble of unfolding it. So,
could it be used without flipping it?
For the outer screen, usually it looks
like a watch for the users to check the
messages. It's like useless. So, we are
wondering, could we still use it to the
greatest degree without flipping it
open? So, another good news for Flip is
that it's a very userfriendly Flip cell
phone without
opening it.
You may not believe me when I say it.
It's just like a powder box size. How
could we use it on the floor without
opening it? We want this.
I plan for the flip. It's a 4 in display
without any camera on it in the
beginning, but I denied it because I
thought without the camera, the video
conferencing or scanning the QR code for
payment or selfies could not be taken.
So, we said no and we must put on the
camera. But the next question is for
such a smallsized display to have
cameras, it looks weird.
That's an issue of software
adaptability.
That's why Android
have the same pain point of software
adaptability. So how did we solve this?
We came up with a very smart solution.
Let's take a closer look.
We have a display area. It's a 3.5 in
display. It's 16 to9 classic ratio and
basically all the software all the APS
could be accommodated.
You might be wondering 3.5 in is that
enough? But never forget that uh our
competitors cell phone used to have the
exact same size. A 3.5 in flip cell
phone
is very
and we can be adaptable
to two cameras and a display area.
All the APS could be used and displayed.
For example, we can accommodate 200 most
frequently used APS like Tik Tok and Red
Book.
Billy or any music APS, they're all
fine. Another edge
with only 3.5 in of display. Our input
is all display. We can support 26
letters or quick dials just like your
usual cell phone.
Common place input box while the display
is only 3.5 in. That's a good idea,
right? And also we have the smart
widgets, the multiunctional widgets,
focus notification
others. Basically all the spaces are
another question that hit you might be
when we close the flip. We cannot call
somebody. We could only listen to the
speaker because of the position. So we
had another idea.
We had the special receiver and mic for
the You don't need to flip it open in
order to call someone. It could be daily
used
without opening it. We invited a female
racing car driver called Ti to test if
this flip could be used for one whole
day without opening it.
Forever
[Music]
speech.
Byebyech.
[Music]
Okay.
very magical. I used it for months
and I still have like 40% battery left
after one whole day of usage. That's a
magical experience. You take just a
powder box every day with you and it
looks cute.
This time our team has new innovation.
It's about the adorable pet wallpapers
on the outer screen. Take a look.
What is it?
Capibara.
And I heard that in the zoos this animal
is very popular right now. I asked why
because it has very steady emotion
control.
more adorable pens to be chosen. Very
cute. You can click it and interact with
it.
For flip cell phones to be good, it must
be beautiful and userfriendly
and also some flagship level
functionalities and experience. For the
other flip years, they don't take the
flip cell phone as flagship product.
They use the previous generations of
chips without the most advanced process.
That's why these other peers might be
easily hated with poor experience. Look
at ours. We adopt the cutting edge
processor, the third generation
Snapdragon 8 with the best internal
storage and also the 3D cooling system,
the 3500 square mm layered VC
stored in such a small size. We can
allow for 4780
mAh edge bigger than our competitors.
unimaginable
just thanks to Xiaomi surge battery and
also 67 watts
search turbocharging. When we designed
the flip, we aim
usability and it's very simple in terms
of performance and
we hope to rival our competitors. Now
let's do a comparison.
I didn't buy it in the beginning. I
asked for a test report. But after
reading the report, I was astonished
playing games compared to our
competitors with full maximum frame
rates.
The hit level is lower than our
competitors. So better gaming
experience. In terms of DOU, we can play
like two more hours of games with um one
and a half hour more of TV experience.
We also invited the media friends to do
some tests with very good reviews. I
would not elaborate on the details.
You might be more concerned with image
photography because we have a lot more
female users of Flip. So, they're very
interested in the photography function.
Many
cameras
were undermined. So people might
question you. You have such a thin cell
phone. How can you have very good camera
performance with dual cameras? Both of
them are 50 mp lens. The main camera
800 sensors and ultra high dynamic range
performance
and also telephoto with a large
aperture.
We adopted sum lux lens
from lup. Not one camera is expedient.
So this is a snapshot by the main camera
with a lot more details.
This is 2x telephoto with high quality
image.
To add some more information for the 2x
lens, we can support floating focal lens
and we also enable the macro
photography. What's good about it? For
many girls using the flip, they can use
it to shoot their pets. very clear
views. This is the facial expression of
a cat. And according to their feedback,
it's also a good choice to take photos
of their makeup or their earrings. So,
it's very good choice for the close-ups
and also it's a good choice for video
taking. Besides, as a flip cell phone,
there might be a lot more new experience
generated. It supports 45 degree to 120
degree of hover photography.
So you could take photos from
the floor to have longer legs in your
photos, but not usable for me because I
don't need it with long legs. And also
you could take photos from
to have a smaller face in the photo. And
you don't need a tripod to take photos.
Especially outdoors, it can be hand to
take photos.
Very convenient to carry and also
suitable for v-log because of its small
size. It looks like a small portable DV.
And the key is when you take videos, it
has the beautify functionality.
Very cool for the girls.
So that's what we bring to you.
I hope that this product could reverse
your impression of as a cell phone good
for nothing. Do you think it suffices?
So some key points, good appearance,
large outer screen, flagship and lea
image.
This flip is very strong because it's a
flagship flip
with no undermining performance with the
strongest processor and two good
displays
and a lot more cutting edge technologies
mounting on it.
So what is the price?
5,999.
Well, what about the price? I think it's
quite reasonable. And let's look at the
competitors price. I can only purchase
the basic model of competitive one. It
only includes 128.
So for this flip is more fashionable and
has more fun. We can take good quality
pictures and we can use it in different
ways and can help us to have longer
deal. So you can consider whether you
should buy one of the mix flip. We have
three versions. As you can see, we have
different prices. 5,999,
6,499,
and 7,299.
And we also designed two
things. As you can see, this is the
customizable ring case. You can hang it
within our hand as a stand.
And inside there are four cars. You can
change it every day
without changing the ring case. You can
only change the cars inside.
And meanwhile, we also designed the
instant camera kit
if you connect with your phone and to
turn on the instant camera model and you
can print the photos as you shoot in a
very quick manner.
We go outside.
It looks great when you carry it.
The whole kit is 499.
And if you interested it, you can order
it.
These are the two affordable mobiles we
have prepared for you. Isn't that great?
I'm not only the CEO of the group but
also the CEO of the automo department
and uh we also offer special benefit for
our owner of SU7. we can give you
another 2,000
credits
in additional
and both phones are produced from the
Xiaomi's uh mobile smart factory
in the earlier of this year and we
opened up automo factory in Beijing and
today
and I would like to introduce to you
about the Xiaomi mobile smart factory in
Ching Beijing which just being completed
and put into production.
It has many features of this factory.
I'd like to briefly introduce to you.
This is the new generation of the mobile
phone smart factory with a total
investment of 2.4 billion, 81,000 square
meters and an output of 10 million
flagship mobiles. It's a national
benchmark enterprise for intelligent
manufacturing.
And
and one thing I feel quite a proud it
has very high level of intelligence and
has the production line equipment of the
core process all selfnovated.
Our self-innovated rate is about 96.8%.
Since starting from the year 2017, we
work within the smart manufacturing and
to today it took us seven years to build
such a factory. How we achieve this?
Let me share with you more information.
Well, it's quite complex to intro uh to
produce mobile phones. We have a
different parts from different
suppliers. We always joke that a was
produced by different countries.
Actually
several years ago we decided to use the
modular ways for designing and we
categorize those equipments into three
categories and we depos all the work
content into modules with unified size
and unified structures for example and
we have the standard ones and we have
two sides for the production line and
just like building blocks
for each equipment can use the modified
ways to assemble. If you want to change
the process, you can only achieve it as
long as you change the reboot module.
For example, if we have machine for
screws up and we don't need to change
the motherboard and is we just need to
change the module if have more chance I
will share with you more information
later. And this factory is quite
stunning. Well, it realized
digitalization of all elements and uh in
total there are 64,000 data collection
points. Every day it collects 17 pieces
of data and we can also use the AI
technology to view the content of the
device in real time. Let me share with
you a video clip to see the Xiaomi
modern factory in Ching, Beijing. Sorry,
is the
Fore!
[Music]
Foreign! Foreign!
Fore
[Music]
speech.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Music]
[Applause]
After these two motor factories were put
into operation, nizens have called me
the president
of the automo factory. I really like
this title. Thank you. Next is the
annual new release products of the Redmi
is the annual flagship.
Well, it's already been handled.
It has been responsible by our specific
staff. Last year we released the K60
Ultra and was well received by the
market and this year together with the
MediaTek and we won more within the
market today. Today together with the
MediaTek we're going to release the K70
Ultra
as well know that Redmi want to make the
best performing Android phone for the K7
Ultra. Well, it is the dual chipset
flagship and it can be the performance
key. So how powerful is its performance?
Well, first it adopts the most advanced
MediaTek density 9,300 plus chipset
and meanwhile it also used the
customized the independent graphic chip
which is uh 12 nanometers
which is the most advanced among all the
company's graphics chips and meanwhile
redne also adopts the wild 3.0 zero
generation combined with those
technologies. Well, it can be the dual
chipset the dual
powerful ones and normal is full core
performance chip and with the frequency
of up to 3.4 GHz. It is the most
powerful processor. Second, we have
innovated the 3D liquid cooling
technology. It has a concave and canvax
design.
Well, it has be as close as to the
processor the temperature surface on the
processor can reduce by 3°ree.
So in this way we can give more room to
the performance
and the N22 score of the K7 is about as
you can see uh 2 million
is quite stunning in terms of the score
in terms of the media testing and we are
highly valued and we are the performance
team. Now let's look at the video.
Well, people speak really high about it.
Now, let's take a look. The last
generation, it was well received by the
market. Compared with the last
generation, it has been greatly
upgraded.
Let me pride you three examples. First,
well, within the extreme image quality,
if we play for the Hong Kong Star Rio
game
for the Kept Ultra is uh power
consumption is the same, but it has
higher frame rate and is more smooth.
The second test
well within the 1.5 K resolution and 120
Hz coy.
So what is the result? You may find that
for the new K70 Ultra, it has better
image and lower power consumption and it
can achieve the coance for 2 hours. So
what about more extreme situation when
the temperature reach 30° outside? If we
play for the heavy load mode for 1 hour
while for the K uh 7T ultra
can reach the maximum frame rate.
Well, you will agree with me if you
experience it. Well, it is a good
machine for playing games. It can
provide us smooth experience with lower
power consumption and lower temperature
for K70 Ultra.
Well, we think it has the best
performance flagship
and for this K7 Ultra, it has very good
design. It's good looking with good
textures. Let's have a look.
Well, we provide three colors.
[Music]
[Applause]
black, white
and light blue.
And we have the metal
but for this price
counterparts sellly use that well. We
also have the quad curve glass which is
rare used by the competitors. In terms
of the display is 1.5k
flight plane and we also have the ultra
narrow
procedures
as you can see
and meanwhile
it also adopts the Xiaomi shield glass
and has very strong ability to combine
with the sore materials.
And meanwhile, we also used Xiaomi eye
care mode. Well, this is the K70 Ultra.
No matter for the outside appearance or
quality, it has been greatly upgraded
and we can provide you excellent
experience. What about the image? It has
been using the Sony IMX 906
and it is the OS and for the very first
time it has been using the AI large
model
shooting platform. It has been upgraded
in three aspects. The first is the quick
shooting 2.0
And second, and it has a very high
compression and has wide balance, more
accurate and also have a dual focal
length portrait. As you can see, the
whole image system has been upgraded
greatly.
And what about DOU? Well, the battery is
about 5,500 mAh and it also has 120 W
fast charging and it has the longest GU
among all the Xiaomi mobiles. You can
charge to the maximum degree in 24
minutes.
It supports two meters waterproof. So
this year the K70 Ultra, how much is it?
This year after Wan took position as the
manager of redme he's under a lot of
pressure because for redme we want to
pursue extreme price for value for money
but this year the value for money is
greatly challenged when we mentioned the
price of previous uh products I didn't
mention this this year the components
for uh storage and the flash components
their price went up by 85 5% and even
100%. Therefore, we're under a lot of
cost pressure. In order to make K70
ultra great, we have done so many
upgrades.
We upgrade to 5,500 mAh hour battery. We
have the metal frame and also the Xiaomi
shield glass. With so many upgrades,
plus the higher cost of storage and
flash components, Won approached me and
Luton separate times. Honestly, we have
a lot of pressure when we price it. But
in the end,
after thinking about it repeatedly, for
such a flagship phone with this
configuration, if it's uh $29.99, we are
still losing money. Last edition was
$25.99, but in order to support Wong,
the Wong, the price will still be $25.99
R&B. I hope the users of Redmi, you can
also support one. It comes in with four
editions 12 + 256 12 + 512 16 + 512 and
16 + 1TB which is 3599 R&B. I used this
phone for some time. The performance is
great
for a smartphone over 2,000 RMBB. You
can still feel is high quality. You see
the metal frame, the allaround liquid
display, and the three color body, the
Xiaomi shield glass, and uh 2 m IP68.
If this phone is 4,000 or 5,000, this is
normal, but it is over 2,000. I have to
tell you, it is undefeated for phones at
the same level.
So, I hope that users of RedMe, you can
show your support to Wong. And this is
the very first product when he became
manager of Redmi. He's he's under a lot
of pressure.
This time Redmi once again work with
Lamborghini.
Let me present you the K70 Ultra
Champion Edition. Its design inspiration
comes from this racing car. You can see
its appearance is very recognizable. We
also use this twocolor design with 24
processes. We perfectly restored this
color design. Let's look at the details.
You see the Y-shaped line and also the
orange color as well as the bright metal
deco
plus the classic logo of Lamborghini.
All of them are restored on the at the
back of your phone. So you can see a lot
of tension on your phone design.
Moreover,
We also customized the wallpaper and
theme for this phone.
It comes in with two colors. We have
green and also orange. They are both
very beautiful. We also have a short
video about the appearance of these K70
Ultra Championship Edition.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
It's really cool.
I really recommend this phone to the
fans of Xiaomi and the Lamborini.
This K70 Ultra Champion Edition,
it has a 12 GB plus one TB and is priced
at 39.99 R&B.
Isn't it cool? Very beautiful.
So, these are the three new smartphones.
Last year, we launched our new corporate
strategy, human car home smart
ecosystem. After the launch,
the human car home smart ecosystem has
been completed. Just now we launched our
core business, the smartphone. Now we're
going to launch three wearable devices.
These three wearables,
they all look very beautiful and their
performance and their experience are
also amazing.
Therefore, it gives you a very high-end
fuels.
Let me break them down. The first one is
Xiaomi Buzz 5. A semi inair noise
cancelling earphone for earphone.
Comfortable to comfortable to wear is
very important. Therefore, we designed
it to be a semi- inair earpiece. I also
wore it. It feels very comfortable in
your ear. Why? Because it is 4.5%
lighter from the last edition. And the
in-ear area is 9.5%
smaller.
And I also compare it with our
competitors. You can see
it is uh very similar to our
competitors. Very incredible because our
competitors has done very well in their
earphone products.
After making it comfortable to wear, the
next issue we encounter is the sound
quality. Because it is semiopen and this
earphone has very good audio quality. We
support hi-fi.
Its frequency response is two times of
our competitor and its magnetic strength
is 1.4 times of our competitors. Why?
This is because we customized a dual
magnetic driver. Therefore, you can hear
the the bass and also our uh audio
quality is very detailed. In addition,
we also provide studio level lossless
audio. The highest transmission rate is
2.1 megabyte per hour and its
transmission rate is eight times of our
competitors.
So you will be able to hear more details
in the in the sound. Moreover, we
invited Harman Carton to jointly tune
this product. We work with the golden
ear team of Harman Cardon inviting 10
masters to help us tune this product.
It's auditory curve is very close to the
classic classic auditory curve. So this
is the buzz five. Moreover, I want to
elaborate on uh some other points. It
supports active noise cancelling, call
noise cancelling and dimensional audio.
Moreover, it also supports call
recording. When you are making a phone
call, you can tap your earphone three
times, you can start recording. This is
actually designed for the user of our
competitors. I know our competitor's
product still does not support call
recording. Therefore, I really suggest
the user of our competitors change to
Android phones.
So this I recommend this to the users of
our competitors. It comes in four
colors. First is titanium color.
You can see it is very classy and
high-tech.
It also comes in blue. It is very
suitable to wear it in summer. For such
a high-end earphone, it is 699
R&B. Very beautiful.
Next up will be Xiaomi Smart Band 9.
This is the ninth generation of smart
band. It gets more and more beautiful.
Let's take a look at the video of its
appearance.
[Music]
I'm not
Let's get it la.
It's too hard to touch.
Laoo
la.
Isn't it very beautiful and uh
fashionable? Let's look at the upgrades.
First is its texture. It has a colorful
metal body. In the past, we used
plastic, but this time we made it a
colorful metal body.
It comes in pink, blue, silver, and
black.
On the basis of the existing straps, we
add another seven straps.
We have hollow bracelets design for the
strap. We also have chain strap, the
dual tone leather strap.
You can also use the pendant design.
We also have three new straps.
One is the magnetic strap.
You can just put it on your hand.
It also has the braided strap and also
irregular metal strap that really suits
our gentleman.
Last but not the least, we also have a
ceramic edition.
Clear, warm, and gentle as a jade.
So, we prepared different editions of
the smart band. All exquisite. We also
upgraded the experience. It has a watch
level linear motor. NFC now supports car
keys.
Now we support two car uh two car brands
and we welcome more car brands to
contact us. The DOU is 21 days.
It is also boosted by a high precision
heart rate sensor. The monitoring is
more accurate. The uh monitoring
accuracy is improved by 16%. It also has
very precise and accurate sleep breath
monitoring. The monitoring accuracy is
improved by 7.9%.
This is a cooperation with the number
three hospital affiliated to PKU. It is
a research on sleep sleep breath health
and uh the hospital help us to finetune
and optimize the data. We are now
working deeply with many hospitals to
make sure our wearable devices can serve
your health. In addition,
The experience is wonderful. So this is
Xiaomi Smart Band 9. It has more
features.
The price is 249
and 299 for the NFC edition, 249
for the ceramic edition NFC.
The straps they are beautiful and uh
also very affordable.
This has already become a beautiful and
fashionable product. I think our
wearable device team is making our
products better and better. And up next
is Xiaomi Watch S4 Sport.
This is a professional sport watch and
this is also the most high-end smart
watch presented by Xiaomi. Let's take a
look.
[Music]
Why is this smart watch high-end? It has
titanium titanium body.
It also has sapphire glass in the front
and at the back and even the rotating
crown is made of titanium. Therefore, we
used a lot of high-end materials. And in
terms of the performance, it is greatly
upgraded. It has a high precision heart
rate SP2 sensor. It supports 40 m
diving. It supports five-star dual
frequency GNSS positioning. It also
supports offline map independent eim.
You don't have to bring your phone. You
can still listen to music, make phone
calls, and send messages. So when you go
jogging, it will be very convenient. for
such a high-end smart watch. It has a
DOU of 15 days more importantly.
This time we work with Santo
and they provide algorithm support to us
and we work with their Finnish team to
adjust this team to really make this
product professional.
Santa offered us a lot more high
performance parameters with more
professional sports guidance. For
example, in terms of threshold, it
allows us to have a better idea about
our aerobics ability. And also in terms
of navigation, it supports passback
which means in the wildlife you don't
get lost easily outdoors. you can get
easily back and also it can give us
alarm about bad weather based on
pressure and altitude monitoring. If it
is senses any huge changes in the
environment it can send alert to you and
also exercise effect evaluation could be
done to avoid over exercise and also it
supports a lot more different scenarios
for example trail running, rock
climbing, hiking, mountain and skiing.
for such a professional smart watch.
What about it? Let's listen to the
restoration has been in our DNA since
1936.
So when we learned that clim also wanted
its users to experience the joy of
outdoor exploration, we immediately hit
off with the sentiment, we want to go
out, adventure starts here.
Xi already has an algorithms for V2 max
and recovery and soon offers other key
feature such as lactate threshold which
can help you achieve peak training
performance.
We have added root allocation and
backtracking to CM's existing offline
maps and dual band GSS
by monitoring parameter pressure. We
provide timely severe weather honors to
help you avoid danger in advance.
Same smart technologies bring new ideas
to outdoor sport such as tandem calls
SOS energy function. I believe our
cooperation will give you professional
and safe outdoor experience.
[Music]
This highend smart watch. It has four
different straps including
fluor strap
braided strap and
lsr strap.
It's very lightweight, easy to wear. And
also we have a luxury choice, the
titanium strap. It's also good looking
for such a professional sports high
quality smart watch. The price is
usually set at 5 to 6,000 or even as
high as 10,000 by our competitors. But
for Xiaomi watch as for sport we have
a very good price 1,999
there are three different packages. Some
have floral rubber 1999. The LSR 1999
titanium and millennia strap. The price
is $2599.
Of course, if you want to change your
strap,
we also have two straps for retail
purchase.
As I said, those wearables
have been improved.
years ago we entered into the business
of high-tech home appliance and in that
field we are performing
with very good reputation. The first one
I want to introduce is air purifier.
This year marks the 10th anniversary of
air purifier. For the last eight years
in a row, we had the number one sales
and with 40% of market share.
Now, on the occasion of the 10th
anniversary of our air purifier,
we bring to you the highest end product
of its kind,
the Xiaomi all scenario air purifier.
What does it mean by all scenario air
purifier? We usually targeted at PM2.5
before but now we have four
functionalities of deodorizing for
mehide removal, smoke removal and
sterilization and disinfection. So it
covers basically all scenarios. Let's
look at the console. It can do all of
the monitoring. If you look at the
contents, you could be aware about the
functions PM2.5 for meldahhide VOC and
others. It has very full monitoring
because of the professional sensors to
monitor six different categories of
pollutants.
Besides, it's a
layered structure with five sets of
professional filters and 10 layered
composite purification system. For
example, PM1 which is much smaller than
PM 2.5. We have a independent PM1
particle sensor. The accuracy of
monitoring is right next to the
professional instruments of the air
purification institutes and hyper filter
screen
has 99.95%
of removal ratio. That's awesome. So PM1
filtering capability is very strong. The
second example is for meltahhide
removal.
It's very difficult. Previously we used
activated carbon technology
to remove for melahhide but there are
several problems with that method. The
first one is after some while uh it will
be saturated
and the second thing is if you don't
change the filter immediately once the
temperature shoots higher there will be
more fromahhide released that is the
secondary pollution. So do you get it?
If you don't change the filter,
the spring immediately
forhide
trapped would be released again. But now
we have a brand new technology, a new
technology.
It's special filter for forldahhide
removal. It adopts a method of catalytic
decomposition to remove fromahhide
and it's seven times the efficiency of
national standard within 1 hour. Removal
ratio could hit 98.92%.
So it's effective for long. You don't
need to change it because catalyst will
not be consumed and there will be no
secondary pollution. So that's like the
best solution ever in terms of for
mehide removal.
In addition, you might need the function
of deodorizing if you are raising pets
at home. And in terms of deodorization,
we have another deodorization filter
layer and ammonia
carbon filter layer.
How do we do it? And what about the
results?
Secondhand smoke is the most difficult
part. Within 1 hour removal ratio, raged
88.29%
the order in the bathroom 96.5%
the stinky smell 99.5%
and patamonia 93.8% 8%.
Very abstract numbers. Give you a good
example. We have such a pet cafe on our
site. We raised lots of pets
and
it's stinky. Within 1 hour, ammonia
removal ratio was 93.8% according to our
test.
concentration of ammonia was down from
to 280. So very strong performance if
you put it in your home.
Additionally, we have high energy UV
sterilization layer to have a full width
light sterilization. If you're allergic
to like virus or other bacteria, then
the removal ratio is 99% and we got
certified
by Germany Lane
certification institute.
So it's very helpful for the allergic
consumers. Since this year marks the
10th anniversary of air purifier, I
strongly recommend this product to four
types of population. The first one is
the people who have home decoration. The
second one pet razor and also mothers
and children. And lastly the allergic
population. We highly recommend these
four groups of consumers to try the
highest
quality air purifier. And of course, our
competitors
have similar products with a price of 7
to 8,000 to 10,000. But for MIT, Osenar
Air Purifier, the final price is set at
5,799.
So, please search for us online.
It's also the highest level
representative of its kind.
The next example is air conditioner.
Lately, Miss Dong has been criticizing
us
saying
that we pretend to be number one. And I
checked very carefully. Nobody has ever
said that our air conditioner is number
one.
Although we did make big progress with
better sales and I did my homework in
the first half of this year. We ranked
number four. We still have a big gap
with Gree which means we have a big room
of development. We must learn from Gree
for that purpose.
For such big progress to be made, it's
firstly attributable to good quality
product, reasonable pricing, and better
services within 3 days. The completion
ratio of installation and delivery is
92.6%,
which means it takes about 1.6 days on
average to complete the delivery and
installation. On June the 20th, we have
installed 85,140
air conditioners alone. So big
investment on air conditioning. That
explains huge progress. Today we're
going to present to you the highest
quality air conditioner. It's fresh air
pro
and it's standing 3P with a dual air
conditioning unit. The height is 1.68 m
with a total area of only 0.15 square
meters. So it's very slim and slender.
And it has four zone air outlets. The
air would just run along the walls with
no direct blowing towards people and
it's noise free and it's it has very
good design to put it in your home.
That's why it won the red dot award.
Another big strength about it is
super primary
energy efficiency. It can save more
electricity. There is a APF indicator
and for our air conditioner it could be
as high as 5.01. Compared to the
national primary energy efficiency, we
can save another 19% of electricity and
that's about 478 mAh per year
and it can save about 786
mAh compared to the old air
conditioners.
energy saving indeed why it's
selfdeveloped by Xiaomi we have won the
second according to the China light
industry federation because of our
technologies and I will elaborate on two
the first one is the top level
denser
so we can increase the area by 83% and
the second thing is we are smart we have
AI energy saving algorithm to save about
40% of energy. AI is influential across
different verticals. And we also have
dual circulation fresh air technology.
Besides, we have iron purification
technology with very strong performance
in disinfection and sterilization.
That's our standing 3P dual air
conditioning unit.
Very good energy performance and other
smart functions. Our peers may be sold
at 13 to 15,000.
And a touching news is about our cost
effectiveness. For Natural Wind Pro, the
price is 6,999.
For fresh air, it's 7,999.
So, please look at us when you are
thinking about air conditioners and do
your comparison.
That's what I want to present to you.
Three cell phones, three wheels, two
home appliances,
Fold and flip. Next Tuesday at about
9:00 a.m. we will start the sales. You
can start your booking right now.
Especially if you prefer the printers,
the photo printers act earlier. We don't
have many
in store. And if you like our purifier,
it also starts the sales since Tuesday
next week. You can start your ordering
right now for the other new products.
They are already online. You can buy it
right now.
In this new decade, Xiaomi has launched
a series of new strategies. For example,
the human car home smart ecosystem, the
technology strategy, AI empowerment.
Allow me to report to you our progress
in large models. We have a sound to
recognize different kinds of sounds in
nature and also to recognize the
emotions and environment
with a sounding. So what's use of it?
The first application is that this large
model will be mounted on the vehicle. We
have additional function of wake up
outside the car.
No matter what is the uh voice
instruction outside the car. For
example, you call for outside the car.
So I may not respond to you.
If you give the instruction outside the
car, that's why our function is
necessary.
Well, shy classmate has been used in
many products for example like your
mobiles, the templates, the automobiles
and uh we have over 100 million active
users for your classmate and later on we
are going to fully upgraded the large
model is fully free so you can
experience the charms of the large model
by yourself.
Next, let me report to you about the
updates of the Xiaomi EV.
Thank you so much. And now we have been
speaking for 2 hours and 45 minutes. And
thank you so much for staying here with
us for so long time. Thank you.
Well, the SU7 has been on the market for
over three months and over 30,000 units
were delivered. It was a miracle
and within such a factory, it was a
miracle to deliver uh so many units.
First good news I'd like to share with
you is that the annual target of 100,000
vehicles is expected to be completed
ahead of schedule in early November.
And I'd like to thank all the partners
on the supply chain. Second
for the sales and service network.
And this month we have added four cities
and
we also added 17 new stores. And
meanwhile the car experience store in
the food center has been re renovated
and reopened. and we will prepare gifts
for you if you are located in Naning.
And uh we will have a lot of uh
different new added centers as well as
service centers.
As you can see right now, we make a big
step forward and we are going to
establish more stores in different
cities in the near futures.
And uh we also have uh many other
products. You can find it within the
auto mall. As you can see that we have
the three pieces for the sunscreen
might not be used by the owners of the
SU7 but we think it's can be needed by
the other brands owners especially for
the female drivers. As you can see the
purple color is quite uh beautiful. We
also have this color, white color.
Well, these colors are favored by female
drivers. As you can see, we also have
the light and air ray sunscreen closing.
Blue, purple, and black. Three colors.
And is a slim type. I have tried it by
myself and is quite comfortable
and handsome.
And we also have the classic baseball
cap with five colors provided.
You need to try advanced
that is quite beautiful.
And we also have the 1 to5 core carfume
with three new added colors. And now you
can order it.
You can start the ordering as soon as
possible.
[Applause]
Okay, now let's look at the goal of the
Xiaomi EV.
Well, our goal is to become one of the
top five car manufacturers worldwide
through 15 to 20 years of hard work. And
we need courage to compete head-to-head
with the world's top car companies.
Do you agree with that?
And we need to prove ourselves
and around the world where we go
actually is the new brain north life.
I'd like to share with you a few
information. Well, this is the world's
pinnacle track. It is located in Germany
is the world's longest
uh track but the track is 20.8
kilometers long with 177
corners and a maximum drop of 304 m.
Well, it can be considered as a mecca
for the comprehensive performance
testing on the track worldwide
and uh within the track all the car
manufacturers compete with each other.
For example, like competitor A is the
king of this track and among the top
30s, half of the uh winners come from
this competitor and it is the best car
manufacturer and we need to learn from
this competitor. One and within this new
green life, we need to polish our
skills. I would like to share with
Albert within a decade we want to become
the fastest four-door EV in Noringer uh
North life within 10 years and we will
improve ourself
step by step and we want to be the
strongest one. You may wonder why we
work on the fourdoor car. Well, many
companies has been producing two door
cars to show of their skills. What we
really want to do is polish our skills
and so that everyone can afford this
track level technology and to have this
such premium experience because few
people can made it to the Ningenburg
notch life as we know that it's really
hard to race on that track except for
the professional drivers. It's really
hard to achieve that goal. How
difficult? The majority of the EVs
cannot make one lap within this track.
It seems that is only has 20.8
kilometers, but it needs for peak
performance. Well, we have four
difficulties. First of all, well, it
needs the peak performance and the key
is to keep the output for a very long
time.
And for the later section of this track
is pretty long. Well, it needs the
strong performance of the battery.
And meanwhile, it has a very huge loss
and it needs the extreme downforce and
the weight of the EV is much heavier
than that of the fuel car. So,
lightweight is one of the difficulties.
In the past 10 years, EV has been
challenging this track. until today
only uh seven EVs has been on the
ranking and they have finished the whole
track and within four as you can see we
only have three and you can find the
detailed information on this slide we
have different models from different
competitors
and then you can find the scores and we
have the seven seconds or sec seven
minutes
and we know is really difficult to
challenge this track. So we divide into
two steps. Well, first in the October
this year, we are going to use uh the
prototype to challenge that ranking of
the mass production cars. And next year
when the production car is ready, we're
going to challenge the left ranking of
the production car. So we are going to
take two steps.
So now let's look at this S U7 Ultra
prototype.
You got feel like
[Music]
Yeah.
Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Isn't it cool?
This is Ultra Prototype,
a real race car. Let's have a look.
It has the oversized front lip
U-shaped cannard on both side and two
huge heat dissipation hose on the front
cover.
As you can see is quite stunning. And we
also have the open wheel arches on the
sides, side skirts of very large size
and very exaggerated diffuser at the
tail and oversized spoiler
as you can see. And we also have has the
same button
on the side car.
I designed it by myself. If you like it,
you can give me a warm applause.
So for the ultra prototype, how powerful
is it? Let's have a look about its
performance.
First of all, it has the peak
performance,
how powerful it is. Well, it's equipped
with
the super V8s motor.
Well, this is the selfnovated motor by
Xiaomi and this is the first time that
V8s has been on board.
The power of the one motor is as high as
p.
And as you can see that it is equivalent
to the power of a large V8 engine is
fully self-inovated
and within this ultra prototype and we
have three super motors
two V8s and one V6s
and what about the horsepower is up to
Yes,
it has surpassed
many supercars.
It surpassed those supercars,
not even mentioned comparable.
And second,
it has been used the current second high
power battery pack for the track which
can output 1,330
kW of ultra high power and the peak
voltage reached almost 900 W and the
charging rate reaches 5.2C.
You may also pay great attention about
its braking system.
It has the AP racing racing braking.
Well, AP racing is a very famous brand
has been responsible for the high
performance braking. And this time we
have been
using this fixed caliper made by AC
racing.
And uh we also have u
the racing brake disc and brake pads for
tracks. The maximum temperature can
exceed 800°.
As you know that it's really high
temperature it may be around 1,000
degrees
and since we are EV one of the advantage
of EV is that we can recycle
the power
well we can provide a maximum
deceleration of 0.6G
and if we consider all together it can
provide
a deceleration of over 2.36
g.
Well, if it's over 2.2, it means that a
heartbreak feels like hitting a wall.
So, we need professional drivers to
drive the race cars to change indicator
reduce from 100 km to zero. It will only
takes 25 meters.
So, this prototype is definitely the
most powerful
Four door cars today not one
is the most powerful one. So what about
is the straight line performance
to compete on a straight line? What
about the results from 0 to 100
kilometers?
Well, the acceleration time is 1.97
seconds per hour.
Well, from 0 to 200 km, the time is 5 96
seconds per hour
and highest speed can be over 350 km per
hour. For those parameters, it can be
considered as the fastest four-door
vehicles
among all the EVs and few cars.
Well, when racing within the track, it
has many requirements
apart from the straight line
performance.
Well, it has retrieved extreme light
weight.
If the car is too heavy, it will also be
very difficult on the racing track. It
also adopts full carbon design.
And this full carbon design is much
stronger than the full carbon design on
a foldable display. So carbon fiber is
the best lightweight material. It also
it is also very strong but it is very
expensive.
However, we used the uh full carbon
design without counting our costs. You
see the front lip, the front bumper, the
fender, the side skirt, the body side,
the doors, rear bumper, diffuser,
spoiler,
roof, front and rear bonnets, all carbon
fibers.
100% of the body coverings are carbon
fiber.
Moreover,
even the motor upper plating is carbon
fiber.
The air hood is also carbon fiber. This
is incredible and stunning.
In total 24 places which covers an area
of 15 square meters are carbon fiber. So
in one word it is excellent.
If we want to put it in another way it
it means expensive it also means we are
rich. So my colleague asked me uh can he
buy an SU7 ultra prototype and I said
even I cannot afford one ultra
prototype. So let's work on let's work
on improving this car because prototype
vehicle is for the purpose of R&D with
so many carbon fiber plus other
improvements. We have reduced the entire
weight by over 500 kilos
compared with a fuel powered vehicle of
the same size is even lighter. You can
see our competitors.
They are
they are at 1,960
kilogram but we are only 1,900 kilogram
for racing car. There is also the
requirement of aerodynamics. During the
launch event of SU7, you heard the term
drag coefficients.
So the raindrop has the lowest drag
coefficient. We want to improve the drag
coefficient because we want to improve
the range. But for racing cars is all
about downforce. So for racing cars,
aerodynamics means downforce not drag
coefficient.
What have we done to improve the
aerodynamics on the car? Just name a
few. The fixed racing spoiler can give
you an addition 735 kilo uh downforce.
The diffuser can give you 245
kilo down force. The open wheel arc can
give you 153 kilo downforce. The front
bumper canard can give you 30.6 kilo
down force
in total.
They can give you 2,145
kg downforce. That means the downforce
even heavier than the weight of the car.
That means in theory
at extreme speed you are able to drive
this car on the ceiling.
So you see this is downforce is
incredible. You see the monstrous
indicators. I won't go through all of
them. In order to run at the northern
loop of Newberg ring in order to
challenge our competitors, we are fully
prepared. Our team has been working at
Newberg ring for a month.
Today we officially announced that in
early October we are going to challenge
the northern loop at Newberg ring.
During the launch event of SU7, I said
that people must have dream to challenge
our competitor is our dream. Even though
we're not as good as our competitors,
it's fine. As long as we start to catch
up, we are on the way to success.
[Applause]
Even though we are fully prepared, but
to challenge the northern loop at
Newberg ring, it is very difficult. All
car companies wants to challenge Newber
Ring. They all want to challenge the
competitors.
So I hope you can understand.
Maybe we will succeed and it is also
likely more likely for us to fail. There
will be different kinds of hardships.
But please believe in us. We will keep
fighting until the last moment until we
finally succeed.
[Applause]
[Music]
14 years after we started Xiaomi, we
have overcome so many difficulties and
hardships. We have always been chasing
our dreams along the way.
With all the dream chases, we have
created a new chapter of the time. Keep
exploring, keep growing, and keep
succeeding. Courage
is the best response we have for the
time.
Thank you very much. And this is the end
of the annual speech and new product
launch event. If you like the new
products, feel free to go to Xiaomi Mall
and buy them. Thank you very much and
good night.
[Applause]
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home, but a space
to infinite possibilities.
[Music]
Proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish. Completing the human
car home smart ecosystem.
Xiaomi HyperOS.
[Music]
Xiaomi.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat
up
here.
[Music]
Show me.
What?
[Music]
Awesome.
I dream.
[Music]
What?
Shia me.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat
up
here.
[Music]
[Applause]
Shia me.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Shia me.
Are traditional commands necessary in a
truly intelligent world?
In our smart ecosystem, cars will
understand you and meet your needs with
flexibility and versatility.
Devices will adapt to your wants and
flow as you wish.
Homes are not just a home but a space to
infinite possibilities.
[Music]
Proactive and responsive operating
system will anticipate and serve your
every intent. This is the future that we
are developing for you. A life where
Xiaomi EV and over 600 million devices
move as you wish. Completing the human
car home smart ecosystem.
Xiaomi Hyper OS.
Xiaomi
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Show Hey,
what?
What?
[Music]
Let's go.
Oh,
[Music]
what else?